bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 sport on passe tout
de suite au sommaire de l'édition pour
le compte du 5e tour de la coupe de
france de football féminin voisins le
bretonneux recevait bourges sur le
papier deux divisions d'écart en faveur
des berruyères les piscines l'oise
étaient donc condamnés à l'exploit
elle est revenue du cambodge il y a
quinze jours après avoir accroché un toc
30 sur le raid amazones 2014 guînoise
anne-sophie chaste nous débriefera son
raid à elles l ont 15 ans joue au
handball sous les couleurs de montigny
ont été toutes les trois repéré par le
pôle espoir d'orléans immersion dans un
quotidien 100% en balles évidemment vous
en avez l'habitude
en fin d'émission le jt résultats du
week-end mais place tout d'abord au
cyclisme et notre sujet fort
d'aujourd'hui à deux mois des
championnats du monde sur piste qui se
dérouleront à saint quentin en yvelines
vous le savez l'équipe de france a
inauguré un tout nouvel équipement pour
améliorer ses performances
un banc aérodynamique ci comprenait une
soufflerie reportages réalisés avec
elodie moines et yolaine torse
ils l'attendaient depuis trop longtemps
à deux mois des championnats du monde
sur piste de saint quentin en yvelines
les membres de l'équipe de france
peuvent désormais travailler leur
aérodynamisme en soufflerie
moi ça fait au moins dix ans j'attends
ça donc maintenant d'avoir ça
juste auprès du vélodrome à deux
kilomètres de notre l'entraînement c'est
parfait si la qualité des entraînements
tricolore est reconnu à travers le monde
il manquait aux pistards français une
expertise technique
cette soufflerie faisait d'ailleurs
partie du cahier de commandes des
coureurs de l'équipe de france après les
jeux olympiques de 2012 car le retard
sur les britanniques habitués de cette
technologie commençait à se creuser
j'irai que c'est plus une manière de
prendre de l'avancé par rapport aux
autres alors faut d'abord récupérer son
retard affectivement et peut-être
prendre de l'avancé parce
qu'effectivement nous n'avions pas ces
tests en soufflerie ce que faisaient
déjà les britanniques pour partie et l'a
vu le niveau d'expertisé
on espère que on sera même encore plus
pointue en matière de soufflerie que
dans cette pièce les coureurs vont
pouvoir optimiser leur prise au vent ou
encore les puissances développées tout
sera examiné à la loupe
l'objectif gagner ces précieux millièmes
qui permettront de décrocher de nouveaux
titres aux mondiaux et à rio en 2016 ça
va apporter énormément puisque on va
s'améliorer sur notre posture sur le
vélo la position est également
comment se positionner les six il faut
écarter plus les bras ou plus les
rentrées les coudes ou la tête un peu
plus se baisser
en course le coureur représente 80% de
la prise au vent
l'équipe de france a déjà perdu un titre
pour un millième de seconde c'est dire
si dans l'élite du cyclisme mondial
chaque détail a son importance je le
disais dans les titres de ce sept huit
sports parmi les 270 participants de
l'édition 2014 du raid de l'arbre vert
ou raid amazones l'ancien nom univie
noise anne-sophie chaste à intégrer le
top 30 pour la première fois 24e place
exactement de cette compétition 100 %
féminine et pour sa deuxième
participation seulement et elle est avec
nous ce soir sur le plateau du 7-8 sport
comme promis bonsoir anne sophie niçois
merci d'être là sur sur le plateau alors
premières questions j'imagine que vous
êtes très satisfait de votre performance
2014 père fier je suis très très
contente oui c'est quelque chose que
vous avez annoncé quand on chante et on
s'était rencontrés lors de vos derniers
jours de préparation il y avait un
espoir top 40 top 30 et puis on suivez
nous sur les sur deux émissions puisque
ça s'est passé sur cinq jours le raid de
l'arbre vert et puis petit à petit vous
avez grignoter des places au classement
pour arriver finalement 24e ça s'est
plutôt bien passé au final au cambodge
ah oui ça s'est super bien passé c'était
une aventure absolument exceptionnelle
on a en fait on a performé sur sur
l'épreuve de canoë ou en était 20e et on
s'était dit bon c'est bon maintenant on
va descendre on va obligatoirement
décembre que moi la course est pas mon
fort mes coéquipières sont visités bien
meilleur que moi et ils sont toujours
d'ailleurs bien meilleur que moi en
course et en fait on a réussi on a
réussi à te prince maintenir et à
rattraper le retard qu'on avait accumulé
à cause de moi sur une épreuve de vtt
justement sur les épreuves où vous étiez
un petit peu en difficulté vous avez
réussi à vous dépasser à sortir de votre
réserve pour gagner ces précieuses
places au classement
oui ce d'autant plus en fait moi je me
suis blessé le premier jour je me suis
fait mal au genou je me suis démis le
péroné en en espagne et tous les jours
et j'ai et c'est sur ce deuxième raid
que j'ai compris ce que c'était que
qu'une équipe ait qu'un esprit l'équipe
parce que effectivement bon jeu
mais j'avais mes coéquipières qui m'ont
qui m'ont soutenu qui m'ont aidé mais
qui m'ont soutenu psychologiquement et
même physiquement puisque sur la
dernière épreuve
elles m'ont elles m'ont tracté sur le
trafic ce jeu fêter le boulet de
l'équipe et elles sont vraiment été
derrière moi
c'est justement ce raid pour vous ça a
été un peu le raid du mental parce que
comme vous le dites un blessé dès le
premier jour ça change tout en fin de
compte après berlin sachant ça change
tout oui parce que parce qu'on a mal ça
change tout parce que parce qu'il faut y
arriver parce qu'en plus on est une
équipe et j'ai vraiment compris sur ce
raid là ça a été deux expérience
extrêmement différente et ce raid m'a
fait comprendre ce qu'était réellement
ce qu'ils étaient et ce qu'était une
équipe
qu'est ce qui est à différencier
justement par rapport à votre première
expérience en malaisie en 2013 vous
aviez batum est couvert en sommes voilà
sera en malaisie j'ai découvert j'ai
découvert un raid j'ai découvert ce que
c'était j'ai découvert la difficulté
j'ai découvert le dépassement de soi
j'ai découvert j'ai découvert
effectivement aussi un esprit d'équipé
mais cette année j'étais en difficulté
parce que j'avais parce que j'avais mal
y avait cette blessure qui termine fin
ça reste l écran même grade du soir au
matin et mes coéquipières n'ont jamais
lâché elles sont elles ont toujours faim
allemands toujours soutenu elles m'ont
toujours encouragée il y avait notamment
anne sophie notre anne-sophie dans mon
équipe qui était qui est un véritable
coach vocal et qui m'encouragent et du
début à la fin a fait peut-être que vous
n'avez pas abandonner parce que vous
auriez je peux pas t'en dire mon stop
j'ai trop mal
non non ça je n'aurais jamais fait ça
mais par contre je pense que je ne
ferais jamais je me serais jamais aussi
bien classé c'est avait pas été derrière
moi pour pour me soutenir pour nous
motiver pour m'aider pour continuer
l'aventuré jusqu'au bout alors dans un
raid il ya toujours une épreuve qui sort
un petit peu du lot par sa difficulté
cette année au cambodge
est ce qu'il ya une épreuve justement
que vous avez détesté entre guillemets a
complètement
c'était le troisième jour c'est pas
moins un jour je craque troisième jour
ce que les quais dernière c'était le
troisième jour on a eu cinquante deux ou
trois kilomètres de vtt dans le sable je
précise que c'était dans le sable parce
que c'était un enfer et on a posé notre
vtt belloni ils ont voulu nous faire
courir je sais plus était quatre ou cinq
cents mètres
sachant que il faisait 40 degrés est
donc là c'était preuve ça a été une
horreur mais vraiment une oeuvre a l'air
un peu compliqué est-ce que du coup
quand on revient encore une fois pour la
deuxième fois je le disais tout à
l'heure d'un raid comme le raid arbre
vert on a un petit peu le raid blues un
peu difficile le retour à la maison
ah non le retour à la maison j'étais
ravie parce que j'y retrouvais à j'ai
retrouvé mes enfants j'ai retrouvé ma
famille etc
mais déjà on a un chat thermique tuque
un fût pas complètement négligeable
on rentre on n'a pas dormi depuis depuis
un bon moment et puis le raid surtout
sur la fin c'est la préparation il a
fallu chercher les sponsors il ya un
entraînement physique il ya un espèce de
vide donc donc très contente de l'avoir
fait de l'avoir vécu très contente de
retrouver de retrouver ma famille est en
même temps un espèce d'effectivement
espèce de vide ça laisse évidemment
beaucoup de vie des données entre
guillemets quand on part si loin pour un
raid aussi important alors le moment le
plus fort peut être de votre rêve 2014
c'était con quel jour sur quelle épreuve
quel moment le moment les plus forts
d'un point de vue humain ça a été le
dernier trek qui a été très difficile
pour moi c'était de la dernière épreuve
est où là
violaine et anne-sophie mon
m'ont porté au sens pur sens physique du
terme mais au sens psychologique et
elles m'ont vraiment porté donc ça a été
un moment pour moi extrêmement fort au
niveau humain et au niveau sportif
au niveau sportif vous avez fini dans un
monde dans mon classement on va dire et
puis fier justement de votre performance
sportive tiennent à l'école aucun nouvel
qui a été notre plus grande performance
mais même après sur le pratiquement tous
les jours très sincèrement c'est
en tout cas moi j'étais fier de ce que
j'arrive à faire oui ça a été une grande
surprise
j'étais fier et d'un point de vue
découverte l'un la journée surprise avec
la chasse au trésor dans les temples
d'angkor reste je pense que ça restera
un souvenir
et justement vous en parler un petit peu
le raid on sait très bien que c'est ce
genre d'épreuves sportives qui renforce
les liens les relations humaines
là vous avez trouvé deux amis à l'autre
bout du monde pourra se dire oui j'avais
pas de doute sur notre sueur sur note
sur notre entente et sur le fait que ça
allait bien se passer mais oui vraiment
c'est je pense qu'il ya un lien
indicible qui c'est qui s'est hissé en
tout cas pour moi faudrait interroger l
maintenant comme vous le disiez un petit
peu dans le reportage qu'on avait fait
il ya quelques semaines vous étiez
devenu un peu a dit au raid amazones
puis au raid en général parce que vous
avez besoin de repousser vos limites
c'est encore plus le cas après ce retour
de cambodge
ah oui j'ai pas l'intention d'arrêter
normalement j'en fais un autre dans deux
mois si mon genou me le permet la sapn
la saharienne et j'ai hâte jadi partir
alors dernière question avant de vous
quitter j'imagine quand même que vous
êtes revenu un petit peu abîmé entre
guillemets puisque il y avait ce genou
un peu récalcitrants tout va bien
maintenant les examens sont passés il
n'y a pas de maintenant les grosses les
genoux est toujours récalcitrants et on
sait pas trop mais
en l'occurrence on sinon je suis en
pleine forme samar booster en tout cas
ça m'a fait beaucoup de bien et donc
d'autres défis sportifs à part la
saharienne on a déjà il ya déjà des
idées d'autres raids à part peut-être le
raid 2015 dollars brevet est gérée 2015
la feria dedans de moi et puis nous ans
après je sais pas des trails il ya le
trail des cathares je crois qui a lieu
au printemps j'aimerais bien essayer de
le faire
ironie pour quelqu'un qui n'aimait pas
courir à la base tout et merci beaucoup
anne sophie est repassé sur le 7-8 fort
en suivra évidemment vos différents
exploits sur les prochains raid on
enchaîne avec le football et pour le
compte du 5e tour de la coupe de france
de football féminin voisins le
bretonneux recevait ce week end
bourges sur le papier deux divisions
d'écart en faveur des berruyères les
filles chinoises étaient donc condamnés
à l'exploit pour rester dans cette coupe
reportage réalisé avec mélanie poker si
le père noël a donné le coup d'envoi
fictif de ce premier tour fédéral de
coupe de france
il n'a pas apporté un super cadeau aux
joueuses de voisins pourtant face à
bourges les v6 noah se procurent les
premières occasions au cours d'une
première période très animée
elle aurait même pu débloquer le verrou
du berry dans le premier quart d'heure
un manque de réalisme sans conséquence
grâce à une exceptionnelle gardienne de
but vie si d'oise
0 0 à la pause il y en a peut-être deux
qu'on peut mettre en première mi temps
puis sur un temps fort je pense que non
si on avait mis une sur le temps forts
en deuxième je pense qu'on les ait
coupés passé n'était pas au mieux et
puis en fait on l'a pas mis et puis on a
commencé à baisser physiquement et puis
elle sur voilà elles ont commencé à
pousser et l'écart de deux divisions
s'est fait sentir les pensionnaires de
division d'honneur continue d'accélérer
après l'heure de jeu alors qu'en face
les joueuses de wilfrid des roches
tiennent tant bien que mal grâce à une
héroïque gardienne de but pour préserver
leur but inviolé
mais à force de reculer voisins se fait
surprendre à quelques minutes du coup de
sifflet final sur ce nouveau centre la
défense saint-quentinoise passe au
travers et permet d'alléger de marquer
l'unique but de la rencontre
les v6 l'oise pousseront jusqu'au bout
mais cela ne suffira pas bourges verra
le deuxième tour fédéral non sans
difficulté de leur côté les joueuses de
wilfrid des roches vont pouvoir se
replonger dans le championnat et tenter
d'accrocher nouvelle montée oui
déception parce que j'étais déjà
convaincu qu'on pouvait faire quelque
chose avant le match je suis encore plus
après donc pour ça que je suis déçu mais
fier de la prestation des joueurs
c'est ce que j'attendais d'elle suppose
qu'elles sont certainement plus déçu que
moi parce qu'ils avaient à coeur de
d'accéder au tour au tour suivant mais
bon voilà une équipe de bourges l'été la
liste nous on n'a pas su mettre celle
qu'il fallait mettre et dans les autres
matches de ce premier tour fédéral de la
coupe de france vous allez le voir pas
trop de réussite même pas du tout pour
les club yvelinois et ce par exemple
montini s'incline sur la pelouse du
paris ca
même sort pour poissy est victime de
caen 3 buts à 2 il ya non que plus de
club yvelinois présent dans cette
édition de la coupe de france pour être
complet sur le football féminin ce
week-end se la jouer quand même dans le
championnat de promotion d'honneur et
l'encours enchaîne une deuxième victoire
consécutive face à nicolette chaillot
succès 2 buts à 1 les amazones sont 8e
de leur poule on enchaîne avec l'inde
et le club de montigny le bretonneux est
un club assez un reconnu pour son aspect
formateur dans le département au sein de
l'équipe - 18 ans des féminines les
qualités de cinq joueuses ont été
repérés par différents pôles espoirs à
travers la france dijon châtenay malabry
mais surtout orléans ou trois joueuses
évoluent toute la semaine au quotidien
ensemble en vivent un quotidien en fait
100 % handball
reportage réalisé avec patrick jacq
dodik elles suivent les cours comme tous
les jeunes lycéens de l'orage pourtant
sarah anna et aminata partagent leur
quotidien entre l'école et les terrains
de handball issus du club de montigny le
bretonneux
ces trois jeunes filles ont intégré au
début de l'année scolaire le pôle espoir
d'orléans
tout juste âgé de 15 ans elles ont dû
s'adapter à cette nouvelle vie 100%
handball loin des amis d'enfance loin de
la famine peser jusqu'à un petit matin
j'ai habité de ça c'est difficile parce
qu'il ya l'éloignement avec la famille
et c'est vrai beaucoup de choses sont
mis en place pour elle donc quand elles
sont en pôle espoir c'est c'est
relativement aisé d'être en pôle espoir
puisque tout est mis en place le lundi
soir il ya une psychologue qui vient
tous les lundis soirs pour les
accompagner il ya un kinésithérapeute
que présent le lundi et le jeudi soir un
médecin jeudi soir donc il ya vraiment
un cocon qui est mis autour d'elle nous
on les suit également dans leur double
projet au niveau scolaire si ça
fonctionne pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
voilà on met en place des aménagements
auxquels sont vraiment suivi encadré
anna c'est un petit peu la belle
histoire de cette promotion
d'abord refusé elle est arrivée fin
septembre pour remplacer le départ d'une
autre joueuse après de rentrée scolaire
et quelques semaines d'adaptation
elle met les bouchées doubles pour se
mettre à niveau la cgt prix c'est une
motivation ça veut dire que je suis doué
donc ou alors qu'on veut apporter
d'autres choses pour que m'ont hélas oui
jusqu'où ils peuvent donc oui c'est une
motivation puis je m'investis geste
m'investir
travail combativité et mental c'est par
là que les inhumant ten s'ouvriront les
portes des centres de formation pour
certaines inspiré par des grands joueurs
comme luc abalo
leurs ambitions sont claires atteindre
le haut niveau tout en gardant les pieds
sur terre et l'esprit à l'école je
reviens l'an dernier
au niveau pourquoi c'est important
qu'elles de continuer l'école
oh quelle raison parce que je leur dit
jamais je me blesse ou seven sécurité
donc en cours par dose de 12 heures par
semaine au pôle les jeune femme enchaîne
les entraînements en moyenne deux par
jour sans compter la session du vendredi
soir avec leur club de montigny et le
match du week-end a même exigence pour
qu à toutes au même niveau
un vrai manque une tige ou le week-end
qui est sûr de jouer moins de 18 c'est
la gardienne inna défis qui peuvent être
meilleures que d'autres qui sont par
paul parce que s'ils sont en formation
en france 24 pôle espoir nourrissent les
10 centres de formation des clubs
professionnels
allez on enchaîne avec le jt résultats
du week end commence ses résultats par
du football une fois n'est pas coutume
championnat de division d'honneur 12e
journée quatrième victoire consécutive
pour versailles les versailles et
s'impose sur la pelouse du racing 1 but
à 0 et confortent leur troisième place
au classement
en promotion d'honneur c'est l'événement
footballistique du week-end après la
défaite du psg à guingamp trap a enfin
renoué avec la victoire les trappistes
se sont imposés 1 à 0 chez le 10e epinay
un succès qu'ils attendaient depuis
trois mois oui oui vous avez bien
entendu au classement trappe gagne une
place et pointe au 9e rang en rugby le
chemin de croix continue pour plaisir
malheureusement après un sursaut lepers
et a rechuté face au solide troisième
niortais défaite 24 à 6 pour le compte
de la dixième journée de fédérale 2 en
promotion d'honneur le sky rugby a
écrasé littéralement stains à domicile
lors de la 10e journée également large
succès donc 57 à 14 avec neuf essais à
la clé emballe fin de série pour
montigny le bretonneux
cette fois-ci cv seniors pour le compte
de la dixième journée de nationale 2
féminine après six victoires
consécutives les in montaigne se sont
inclinés chez le huitième lisieux 25 à
22 et dans le même temps vous le voyez
le leader havrais a connu sa deuxième
défaite de la saison à villemomble 38 à
22 et au classement cela se resserre
considérablement en tête le havre est
toujours leader avec 26 points
villemomble et
c'est devant montigné à la différence de
buts les trois équipes se tiennent donc
en seulement deux petits points chez les
jeunes toujours handball cette fois-ci
championnat de france moins de 18 ans
dernière journée de la première phase et
pas de miracle pour la team 78 si les
joueurs d'alexandre taillefer ont fait
le boulot comme on dit en s'imposant
dans le nord 35 à 21
paris galaxy le coleader a également
gagné face à stella sport 28 à 23 et
vous allez le voir donc conséquence
directe au classement statu quo par aig
alexis fini premier de cette première
phase le team 78 reste 2e et aura donc
une poule de deuxième phase un petit peu
plus difficile à partir de janvier
en basket 12e journée de nationale 2
féminine défaite logique il faut le dire
de l'entendre le chesnay versailles sur
le parquet du deuxième trait 2,87 à 65
les filles de l'ufcv restent onzièmes de
leur poule chez les hommes nationale
trois trappes s'incline à vineuil dans
le match du milieu de tableau
50 à 30 1 très peu de paniers ce samedi
soir et du lcv n'a rien pu faire face à
gennevilliers défaite 97 à 61 en
volleyball de régionales une ont suivi
damman la saison de montigné plaisir et
vélizy 11e journée montini s'impose 3
sets à 2 face à la lanterne rouge
noisy-le-grand même score pour plaisir
villepreux face au leader cormeilles en
parisis c'est la performance du week-end
dans cette poule et troisième victoire
yvelinoise pour compléter le tableau de
vélizy sur le terrain de villejuif 3
sets à 1 et au classement vous allez le
voir cormeilles est évidemment toujours
leader plaisir villepreux pointe au 3e
rang
velizy 5e et montigné un petit peu plus
en difficulté cette saison de transition
pointe au 7e en avant de nous quitter
une dernière info de sports de combat ou
plutôt du muay-thaï et l'entraîneur de
muay thaï duchesnay que vous voyez sur
ces images en bleu stéphane geoffrey
vient d'être nommé à la tête de la
fédération française de montagne et
disciplines associées nous le recevrons
non dans un prochain 7,8 score pour
qu'il nous explique ses projets et
l'avenir qu'il voit pour la discipline
en france
évidemment dans les yvelines c'est la
fin de ce set 8 faut remercier encore
une fois 2
voir suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain
même humeur d'ici là excellent de soirée
sur tf1